thank you
[Music]
all right let's talk about 12 conspiracy
theories that actually turned out to be
true
you know what I [__] go through these
listicles every day all right you guys
want me to guess what yeah yes each one
against which ones yeah total all right
go for talking do you know about the
horror of project Sunshine no no tell us
about it please Perfect Sunshine is
where there was a big conspiracy that
the government was stealing dead bodies
in order to do radioactive testing oh
really all right yeah and they actually
were they were actually stealing body
parts from recently deceased babies what
like babies because it's radioactive
baby we needed young tissue in order to
test with the effect of a radioactive
bomb you needed like a young human
tissue like yeah grave digging
Hospital
they would rather than uh they would
just take parts of the baby off I think
they need to ethically Source the baby
like they can't steal it
they have to it has to be they have to
be organ donors nothing about this
sounds ethical
yeah I don't like that or is that in the
fine print of like having an owner organ
donor type of situation yeah yeah that
sounds like some black market [__] you
know yeah I want some farm-raised
Farm race
Texas baby yep
how about uh you know in prohibition was
a thing yeah the government actually was
putting poison in the alcohol that was
left oh yeah
because they're like so that people
could die from drinking it yeah because
they want to discourage drinking so they
actually made it poisonous
they did some [__] up [__] back in the
day huh yeah not anymore these days nah
not anymore
glad we have a government that's so
honorable and ethical and they don't
[__] up yeah it's for sure it was back
then a crazy one uh you guys know MK
Ultra right yeah that's insane that that
was real is that was that again yeah
it's the testing of uh where they uh
kidnap people or like requesting LSD and
like other hallucinogenics on people but
they weren't telling them that they were
doing that yeah yeah there's just much
movies about that right yeah so people
just uh they were permanently mentally
disabled and the government was like we
didn't do that that's kind of like
somewhat how stranger things you know
how they play with that government like
yeah yeah yeah but it's like they're
also [__] with like telepathy and
like all kinds of weird weird [__] um
because did they make a movie like uh
the one with George Clooney it's like
Men Who Stare at Goats or something oh
is that what oh I think I think that's a
I don't know if that's I'm pretty sure
it's based off a true you know I didn't
know that that I the title just made me
think it was a boring movie so I didn't
watch it pretty but that's the whole
premise is like they're testing out
telepathy Tuskegee experiment yeah they
inject the black community with syphilis
to test them to test the reaction yeah
they gave syphilis to hell and people it
was all black people too right yeah
crazy just like with AIDS right
aids for like lesser or lower income
communities they gave them aids
for that one it is it is a conspiracy
theory I don't know if that one's true
but the about yeah because the Tuskegee
one is I don't think they knew about
AIDS back then it was just syphilis yeah
do you guys know about the Dalai Lama no
yeah he's a fake he's a pedophile no
he's not I don't know about that but oh
wait he works as a spy for the US
government yeah he's a CIA agent is he
it turns out he um they don't I mean
saying he's a CIA agent sounds a little
general he's like an informant or that
he receives a salary from the CIA
interesting to do what this all the time
so the purpose of the Dalai Lama in in
the um that's great from the perspective
of the CIA if he's there to destabilize
China's infrastructure
kind of like um it says like uh yeah he
earned 180k that's it
I think a year I would have been like
bro the pope makes way more cups
in order it's like he he has a
figurehead for the Tibetan resistance so
Tibet versus China kind of thing wow so
like to maintain this like morale I
guess against China when were they
paying him 1960s dude 180 000 in 1960s
I'm just killing it I thought it was
today yeah
and then uh John Lennon being under
government surveillance ended up being
true yeah because why would they what's
the story on that because he was making
songs that were anti-war oh and I think
anybody who did that at that time was
under surveillance yeah we're checking
you out but then he would be number one
because he was the top of the top right
yeah so the yeah there's actually files
on him and stuff even though like
Operation Paperclip so Operation
Paperclip is after World War II they
were like what are we gonna do with all
these Nazi scientists that are kind of
chilling and they're like
um maybe we'll give them a home in
America and that's where um they became
leaders of NASA and CIA and all these
because they're like well we got these
fresh brains we don't want to let a
splatter
let's just use them for our benefit damn
so we have a lot of uh Nazi scientists
that are that were contributing to
American you know progress in in science
and stuff is Oppenheimer one of them I
think so no sounds like a very German
name yeah all right this one's kind of
recent the whole NSA thing how people
were like the government's not spying on
us and then people are like yes they are
somehow uh yeah in truth 2016 there were
50 000 requests from the government to
Facebook 27
000 to Google nine thousand to Apple and
that's all just to get private
information that's not I didn't see
Snowden already
that information yeah but nobody listens
yeah nobody cares where's he at now
Russia Russia right he's still chilling
over there yeah how about the freaking
uh the Gulf of Tonkin Gulf of Tonkin
yeah that's what started the Vietnam War
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was a false
flag yeah false flag so what was this
one all right that's the one where it's
um they faked the first move so it was
like uh they basically attacked their
own uh not attacked their own ship but
they attacked Vietnam and made it look
like Vietnam had attacked American ships
so give them the right to be able to
we'll go to war with them yeah and then
they said that's the direct uh one
incident that begun the Full Assault you
know what America was he was that guy at
the bar that's been wanting to fight and
then he did why get into why you [__]
run into me man what you trying to fight
now yeah and then the guy's like no I'm
cool then he's like it was him yeah see
he takes out the bottle and goes like
this yes
and then here's a knife do something
with the knife
do something with a knife in the 1950s
uh
big tobacco already knew cigarettes
caused cancer they didn't say anything
become a headline until 40 years later
1950.
whoa the movie called thank you for not
smoking yeah that's great maybe you want
to smoke a little maybe you want to
smoke
Those Old School advertisements where
doctors are like it's doctor approved
yeah that [__] blows my mind I think uh
later in my life like when I get like
60s 70s I'm gonna start smoking I think
probably I'm gonna start it dude
watching prolonged your life for like 20
years my whole family like smokes like
this and you never wanted to because I
felt like once I started you're gonna
turn into them I'm gonna I'm gonna be a
[__] for sure smoker it has to be so
hard for me to stop um did you figure
that out because it Pringles it's
because of black and Miles
I haven't touched a cigarette ever since
my grandma would smoke all the time she
lived in New Mexico and anytime she'd
send packages to US in La it just smell
like cigarettes and you're like
oh did she go like this yeah
this one I never even knew about but in
the 1960s the Canadian government was uh
funding this
machine that apparently was supposed to
be the first gaydar
[Laughter]
when we were talking about the Chachi
how would that even work though
like what would it be like tracking I
think it might have been like a
seismograph or like a lie detector or
something like that oh that's so
ridiculous we were talking about that
ends up just being a sensor as well
everybody's gay the what wait there was
a Gatorade gbt no no we were talking
about this uh recently the project the
other project but I feel like that was
in tandem with this uh machine that was
built with Canada to all the study yeah
the study we were talking about chat GPT
pulling like or Dan pulling like
statistics and stuff but I'm like is
that statistic really just like based
off I wonder what they were like yeah so
the way that the device works so the the
point first of all it's crazy because
the point of the device is to prevent
gay people from like working in high
positions like they don't want gay guys
in Civil Service military they want to
find them like oh you're gay get out so
then they would do this thing where it's
uh it's a device that measures your
pupil dilation when you're shown gay
porn oh so that's what that is because
you're horny yeah well it's kind of a
logical approach I guess yeah why they
measuring the pupils when they could
measure the BP
you're getting stimulated right you're
just like oh like you're focusing a
little bit harder I guess but it's like
I don't know how like does that really
work for anything like if you're showing
something you like I have no idea you
might I have theory on it but I don't
think it's been proven right but yeah
they actually in the 60s were but for
them to use it so they can kick gaze out
like that's so crazy and the point
wasn't to find who's gained societies to
find who's gay and like upper echelon
like things yeah that's so funny upper
management exactly we can't have the
barracks start looking like purple and
nice and fabulous like they don't want
no gays in the military because they're
gonna make it all fashionable because we
were gonna have fabulous Barracks we had
to stop this I know like what are they
afraid of yeah that's that to me was the
out of this list that was a crazy one
because I'd never heard of them
[Music]
laughs
foreign